[Music]
hey folks you've got questions we've got
answers welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 95q and a
section we are ready to go we should
warn you up top
we are several questions in here going
to terminate the youtube feed due to
draconian authoritarian regulations on
the youtube platform and we will be
going over to odyssey where we can talk
like adults about things that matter so
the link is in the description for the
youtube
feed the youtube if you are watching on
youtube right now you will find at the
top of the description the link to the
odyssey q a which is concurrently
streaming right now and we'll continue
to stream after we drop this one so
we're going to start by answering
several questions that um at least
as far as we can tell are unlikely to um
irritate any sensors and then we will
give you another warning before we
terminate youtube feed
and then we'll start with the question
from the discord this week and uh answer
as many of the others here that came in
that um seem to be um
all on a particular set of topics that
uh youtube really does not want us
talking about no it's not no
all right
so however first uh while we're still
live on youtube what makes religion and
social movements so damned effective at
getting people to comply with set
behaviors so damned quickly i can't even
get my kids to put their clothes in the
hamper and i've been training them for
over a decade maybe i can pick up some
tips lol thanks for your time
and here's to another decade of trying
uh social media puts the dope in
dopamine
and
it's not bad it's not great but
it's not bad i i know that you it wasn't
derivative on your part because you
don't do that sort of thing but i'm sure
it's been said before oh no yeah if not
the shame is on other people for missing
it for this everyone else yeah
um
right look here's the thing you've got
markets
and those markets are well but religion
i mean you're not going to blame
religion the efficacy of religion on
markets are you no i'm sorry it's
possible that i
misunderstood a word or two in the
question what makes religion and social
movement so damned effective at getting
people to comply with set behavior i've
heard social media and that's why i
thought dope and dopamine please
erase what i said
no
in some sense
markets very efficiently quickly find
defects in cognition because effectively
you've got all sorts of people trying
and those that land on a formulation
that exploits some blind spot work
religion
works because over long periods of time
what you have is selection searching for
things that result in behavior that ends
up being adaptive so i take back that
was targeted at social media that was
not targeted at religions basic point is
religions are
compendiums of wisdom that has stood the
test of time does that mean that they
are up to date with respect to modern
problems it absolutely does not because
we are in circumstances that
the ancestral environments that formed
those religions do not look like i mean
i guess
even more precisely to the question
i would argue i mean religion and social
movements are a bit different here so
you know using the model that we were
discussing in the first hour uh religion
um
religious injunctions that get people to
do things that the religion wants and
that the individual might have another
thing in mind
tend to be the most effective when they
are in that sacred layer when they are
in that this is how we do things if you
are part of this religion this is how
you do things
um and so it's not a matter of so
quickly actually it's a matter of this
is what you do if you are an ex you know
member of this group and you know social
movements i suspect are going to operate
the same way there's less formalism in
social movements than there is in um you
know there are less established um
received wisdom in the form of texts in
social movements well i would add that
basically these things function on two
different time scales and which two
things religions and social movements um
religions have an advantage arguably
this advantage applies less and less but
to the extent that you are
an ape that is born into a group that
has uh
teachings that it hands to you many of
those teachings are the key to your
success and some of those teachings say
very ominous things about what will
happen to you if you depart from
the sacred wisdom and you are in no
position to determine that those
penalties may not actually be real so
what we have argued
um here and in the book and elsewhere
is that
a belief in an afterlife for example is
not a literally true belief there's
nowhere to go on the other hand it's an
analog for something that's very real
and very hard to say right so before
anyone understood that there were genes
that were trying to get into the future
there was a belief about pleasing a god
who controlled something about you that
would continue into the future right
when you can't say hey actually
your genes need to get into the future
in order for them to do that well you
need to
restrain your behavior while you're
physically present because that will
affect your descendants position in the
universe and they carry your genes even
after you're gone if you can't say that
then you can say behave well and get
into heaven and live terrifically ever
after otherwise really bad like a fire
stuff is gonna go on and you don't want
any part of that right so those extreme
penalties and extreme rewards shape
behavior rather dramatically because
life is short and the afterlife ain't so
um you know the calculus is pretty
simple
now at the point people start saying you
know maybe that afterlife stuff isn't an
actual thing now you've got a problem
because even the thou shalt and thou
shalt not now doesn't carry a calculus
that makes it obvious that you should be
striving for something and those who
depart most may actually do best in this
life right especially in the context of
things that are not communities where
your reputation
precedes you and dictates how people
interact with you but you walk away with
this fungible currency and you can do
terrible things to people make a lot of
money and then go spend it somewhere and
nobody treats you like a bad person
right those opportunities are new
and anyway so this is this is where we
are the predicament is the old system in
which people simply believed what their
elders told them and it was very
frightening and very encouraging
depending upon what sort of person you
were that was pretty persuasive now it's
not so persuasive and we don't have the
substitute system what we really have is
people exploring what they can get away
with and finding out they can get away
with a lot absolutely and there's
something you said in there that i had
never put together before and i'm sure
i'm sure others have but um the idea
that the fungibility of currency paves
the way for anonymity
in human interactions is um really
important yeah it's uh it's quite quite
bad so the uh the other thing though the
social movement issue is that social
movements are much shorter you know
these aren't thousands of years old
typically yeah they tend to come and go
and they make they may come back they're
more like fashion trends
um and you know that's that can be taken
out of context of course but they're
they're shorter term and they tend to do
resurgences as opposed to like we're
here we're here for good but in some
sense um you know there are traditions
in which
uh the rewards and penalties of the
mystical layer come to you in this life
and there are other traditions in which
they await your death
and the social movements are more like
in this life you know if you say these
things and you behave in these ways then
you will be you will rise with our
movement well and it's i mean social
movements are in general explicitly
fighting for the material you know
improvements in the material world right
they're not they're not fighting for
improvements in the afterlife right well
that's it and you know to the extent
that they work and you know let's not
forget that as absurd as the social
movements that we seem to have are many
social movements have succeeded in doing
really important world improving stuff
and so there is a serious version even
if our current versions are malignant
um but you know they have to work
somehow yeah okay let's that's one
question let's try to get through a few
more here
why are women more prone to developing
eating disorders explanations like
sexism and oppressive beauty standards
seem incomplete and shallow if you
consider that gay men make up the strong
majority of male
eating disorder sufferers
um
i would say that you know gay men and
women have
some some similarities of course and yes
um the sort of the social
the social construct types of
explanations like sexism and oppressive
beauty standards that don't include any
evolutionary analysis are as you say
incomplete and shallow but it's not that
they don't have the the a germ of truth
there that um
you know
sexism is like the pathological version
of recognizing that there are sex
differences
and the sex some of the sex differences
that we have include the fact that um
you know men and women look different
and um as we are moving from a more
strictly polygenous past towards a more
monogamous existence we have not just
female choice of male mates and male
male competition but also
male choice of female mates and female
female competition and so
um
focusing um
your attention as a woman on how it is
that you look has been a decent stand-in
for you know it's a decent proxy for am
i going to be able to
win in the mating and you know dating
and mating game and um in competition
but you know both in terms of attracting
a male mate for talking about you know
and prediction also would be that
homosexual women have lower levels of
eating disorders um so in in terms of
attracting a mate and also in
competition with other women
and you know youth
uh
youthfulness and uh basically
reproductive
vitality um
being indicators of fecundity uh which
have been indicators of um which have
been the things of course that um points
to reproductive success
in our our history those are the things
that women get focused on now eating
disorders that cause women to become
ever more thin
uh which frankly almost no one finds
actually attractive and is not healthy
and does not lead to reproductive
success at all is obviously you know
it's it's beyond pathological it's it's
it's very much a disorder but the idea
that
women looking to attract men and to some
degree some men looking to attract men
will use
youth and sexual vitality um as the
thing in their head that they get ramped
up and can focus only on that and that
that's the you know that's the error um
that they exaggerate as opposed to
someone else who will exaggerate you
know something else um
shouldn't be surprising given this
evolutionary framework
all right i'm gonna try a little
sacrilege here um
this is
new at least for me but i
kind of have the sense there's something
here all right um
this has to do with the fact that there
is a lot to say about
females being um
much lower variance that is much more
likely to succeed but the range over
which success and failure exists is much
narrower and manageable across domains
domains and men are a huge gamble right
there are lots of crosstalk across
domains there are lots of losers and
when men win they often win big
all right now
the point is in that universe right
let's just take prototypical male
prototypical female
a male
if he invests this is in the ancestral
past a male who invests in male
endeavors and succeeds
has a much higher chance
reproductive success wise right
better choice of mates those offspring
that are produced are liable to be in a
much better position to capitalize on
opportunity and all of these things
right
so that male variance
uh is of high value it is of high value
to females who are looking to incr
improve the position of their offspring
in the world which of course they are
right so female focus on what males are
interested in
is
uh
a male can demonstrate his capacity
almost irrespective of what he looks
like if he succeeds in the world in some
way that demonstrates uh inside ability
to get ahead what even if it's
ruthlessness whatever it is
right that thing
reduces the priority on uh
male
you know beauty standards let's say
whereas females looking to
uh improve the position of their
offspring by
finding a mate who will be able to
capitalize on the positive side of the
high variance is a priority now here's
the important part important part is
that is all fairly
straightforward
in this environment you now introduce
advertisers right now advertising works
on the basis of triggering insecurities
what it does is it causes people just
hold on it's like you just introduced a
hypothesis which is the eating disorders
basically don't exist outside of the
advertising regime i think that's
basically true right
they're not
you sort of introduced it as an
assumption but it could also be um
voiced as a hypothesis let's voice it as
a hypothesis i'm not too worried about
it yeah um but just
anyway it's it is necessary it's
necessary that that be true for i don't
know where you're going but i think it
will be necessary that that be true for
where you're going to go forward so
advertisers adjust what gets bought
that's their purpose
right they can adjust which thing you
buy in a sequence of things where you're
going to buy something or they can cause
you to buy something that you weren't
going to buy otherwise but basically the
way they do this is by triggering
dissatisfaction right if you're
satisfied you're not buying if you're
unsatisfied you'll buy so if i say oh
you've got a problem honey but i've got
the solution and it comes in this bottle
right then if that's a persuasive pitch
then that bottle is something you want
ah i've succeeded as an advertiser
okay so the point is
women are already attuned very attuned
to what men
prefer right that's natural by virtue of
the problem of huma of male variants
being a key to the success of a female's
offspring in an ancestral past
it is then exploited by advertisers
advertisers who
create a very false sense of what men
actually prefer this is well
demonstrated that
the degree to which
men actually prefer very thin women is
uncorrelated to what women expect men
prefer for example
and so the point is you've got a runaway
process where advertisers are triggering
insecurities and those insecurities
basically set beauty standards that
can't be met by a human female in fact
there was this uh quite interesting dove
commercial some time ago where they
showed how this very beautiful model
uh was made to look levels of beautiful
that
she wasn't by virtue of photoshop and
all sorts of other tricks in order to so
i'm not sure i i feel like we need to
move on we're spending way too much time
here but i'm not sure what the new
i'm not sure what you're saying so for
instance you know we know that and
indeed it's in one of these stories is
in the book
where i think it was
gosh some south pacific island where the
beauty standards
are for rather plumper uh women and that
when tv arrived suddenly you get women
who are dieting and have eating
disorders and so you know this is
actually it's it's it's well documented
that you introduce basically the markets
um the markets which include western
beauty standards and women who live in
cultures that didn't have western beauty
standards start to try to adopt them and
especially if their internal beauty
standards weren't the same thing
suddenly you have eating disorders right
so
the the model is
um because the degree of success and
failure that has traditionally
accompanied male
realms of competition is high variance
and women get access to it through the
perception of males right by attracting
males they're
hypersensitive to what males prefer
which makes them vulnerable to
advertisers portraying male preference
in ways that it isn't in order to
trigger insecurity and so the basic
point is you have an epidemic of female
insecurity that is causing behaviors
that are very unhealthy but really
that's
advertisers interceding in a normal
asymmetrical kind of mate choice so i
think i i want to come back to this
because i'm not i'm not seeing the
connection between the high variance and
the advertisers this is not connecting
for me but i really feel like we're
spending way too much time on two
questions and we'd already said we're
going to spend a lot of time on okay
odyssey only stuff well let's go let's
do the flip side of it okay let's say
that a male is not physically
especially
attractive but he's very good at a
successful hunt or very good at spotting
arbitrage arbitrageable goods in the
market and therefore capable of
demonstrating high value right
a woman in a traditional system
shouldn't overlook that and so therefore
the superficial okay so it sounds like
you're not trying to you're not i
thought you were explaining why women
are doing this it sounds like what
you're actually explaining is why men
aren't no i'm explaining the asymmetry
between men and women and then saying
advertisers have a special there's a
vulnerability and access
to women
um that the same access is not provided
to men because um the ways i mean i
don't think it's about the high variance
though i think it's because the ways
that men attract women is not primarily
through youth and vitality because
that's not generally what men are
offering right but in part
the greater diversity of things
including across the lifetime that um
that tend to be attractive in male in in
males as mates for women so that has i i
don't see the connection to the higher
variability
uh you know across domains because if
females are lower variability in terms
of success the range of success as a
gatherer exists but it's not as wide a
range then the point is what really
dictates
offspring that are very well positioned
versus offspring that are very poorly
positioned is how a woman teams up
because it's lower what what she does in
the world has traditionally been lower
variance so this is like taking um
mating and dating into lineage selection
space and going like okay how how it
doesn't matter that yeah the low
variance means that maybe we can stop
talking about women entirely with regard
to repeat of success except that lineage
selection reveals that we actually need
to focus on um the f1 the f2 and the f3
it predicts it predicts that women
should uh traditionally have viewed the
world this way but i want to add one
last thing which is that this mirrors
the thing that we talk about about the
difference between socially mediated
truth and physically mediated truth
because the difference is um
female value is socially mediated which
is what creates female trade value has
traditionally been socially mediated
which
creates the vulnerability that
advertisers exploit which then creates i
think this is right either
female value is explicitly not
traditionally like there's just there's
competition over social space but it's
the actual physicality like dude we have
so many questions to get through let's
do it but it's the variance i'm talking
about not the not the absolute okay i'm
not i'm just i'm gonna stop responding
um
so there's like 10 questions that are
pre odyssey stuff that i really wanted
to get through
um
what's with raspberries another thorny
fruit fruit to get you to spread their
seeds but thorns to add blood or
dissuade i just wanted to i'm not
necessarily answer this directly but say
that actually my natural selections post
for next week is about fruit
um this one's easy
sure okay it's about birds it's supposed
to dissuade things like deer which may
poop out the seeds uh feet away from the
plant and encouraging birds which will
fly the seeds long distances which is
the whole point in the fruit yeah but
raspberries are like we have selected
raspberries to become a human thing and
we haven't selected out the thorns um so
you know the the fact that they're red
like red fruits tend to be bird fruits
yeah but we obviously there's lots of
red fruits that we have selected to be
perfect for our tastes and aversions to
secondary compounds right but it may be
that this is the genetic equivalent of
sacred that thorns have been such a key
in that lineage to not being dispersed
by the wrong critter that they're very
hard to select out or it may be that
they actually keep our pests away and
that because we're humans we're capable
of reaching around thorns and figuring
out ways to harvest stuff and so that
actually the thorns have done our
bidding for us
yeah i mean deer deer love raspberries
and blackberries as well
and they you know they seem not to
usually come away with
bloody noses
um
is nose nose-to-tail animal-based diet
evolutionary consistent is the question
data seems ambiguous so i don't know
what consistent means i don't even i
don't understand the question yet
knows to take an animal-based diet so
when you're eating the whole part of the
the entire part of the animal
i think i mean there's kind of not quite
enough words here um but
uh
yes if you know it is it is very likely
that eating more parts of the animal
will actually make a person healthier
than just eating the muscle which is
largely what humans do but there are you
know
organ meats are very popular in many in
many cuisines and frankly some of those
organ meats
are almost certainly really not good for
you you know the things that are
literally detoxifying you you know
livers and kidneys are um rarely going
to be very uh very healthy for you uh i
don't i don't know about this there are
cases in which this is true carnivore
liver for example is no good right
um i think this is it's certainly true
that it to eat liver involves a cost
right is that cost worth paying probably
in general but i would say the missing
piece but it's also i mean it's also
high in for instance iron which in some
environments is limiting right
the real question is this why would you
ever leave calories on the table and
there are really only a couple reasons
because those calories are tied to
something hazardous to you like a toxin
because those calories are too expensive
to access so they're actually net
negative right there are lots of things
you could eat but you know you would
have to spend too much hunting effort to
get enough of them
or they're too deep inside some bone and
you can't get it
easily so the real question is the
mystery is why do we not eat certain
parts
of animals and the answer is not worth
the cost in one way or another either
because of toxicity because of
difficulty because there's a better use
right if you're partnered with dogs it
may be that liver is perfectly good for
you
but it's better spent on your dogs which
increase your success at hunting or
something like that but the basic answer
is going to be
calories or calories they come with
downsides and there are opportunity
costs like are you feeding you know
would it be better given to the chickens
would it be better given to the dogs
that sort of thing but by and large you
should expect no waste of calories you
should expect the best use of calories
the optimal use
my dog got fleas while camping do you
have thoughts on the best flea treatment
or prevention thank you
um
[Music]
i would be ultra cautious about the
stuff that you put on the surface of
animals this is a really frightening
trend
um
because you can't control where it goes
it's obviously extremely potent stuff
and you're basically depending on the
fact that it interacts catastrophically
with the physiology of the parasites and
not at all with the physiology of
you and your kids and whatever that come
in contact with the animal
and in fact
it is
you know and also and any animal that
grooms itself is going to be consuming
this stuff so i would just say
especially if you've got children i mean
it's just going to come it's going to
it's going to come on to your children
who are playing with your animal yeah um
most of the systemic stuff is really
really toxic as well yep um there's one
thing that we have used in the past on
occasion um and i can't remember the
name of it uh offhand
um because in parts um you know we we
had some grass where we lived in olympia
and we don't have a lawn here we don't
have any grass and we don't have any
fleas
and obviously fleas pre-existed lawns um
but it does seem pretty clear that the
um
that the concentration of fleas that a
lot of modern
pets have
is associated with um grassy lawns
and so we haven't had to we we have not
had to deal with us for many years now
yeah that's that's true
i would also say the ugly part of this
is
you probably should do the calculation
do i prefer
some harm to my pet to protect the
humans in the environment
and i think it's the right thing to do
though it's not a very yeah and we have
and i guess one i just one other thing
is that i used to um
there's some efficacy to the botanical
penny royal you can buy penny royal oil
and i would spray it by the cat door by
the dog door
and it seemed it seemed to keep some of
the fleas at the door as opposed to
coming inside
yeah
this is just a nice comment love how you
both engage breath and depth in all that
you discuss as a 7 to 72 year old
australian female i look forward
um
to being in your book
um yeah let's fight over this one
and this is funny is there a difference
between mostly sunny and partly cloudy
is this scientific looking forward to
reading your book
i suspect it's a percentage thing you
know meteorologists must have some like
description and they just haven't
bothered to tell us because um
if it's really the same thing it's
completely ridiculous but i think it's a
percentage thing i think it's undefined
and i think an amazing number of
statistics that get reported you cannot
chase down what they mean because they
don't actually mean anything this isn't
a statistic this is this is a category
that meteorologists right but but i
think
i will be shocked if it's undefined i'll
bet it is variable
across across places
but then that is undefined right if one
app calls it one way and another app
calls it another way then that's an
arbitrary choice and it's there's no
standard to appeal to but i would say
even you know
something obvious like an 83 percent
chance of rain yeah it is not obvious
what that means is it raining
at any one
my son is telling me there's a very
simple answer
well i was going to ask i don't believe
that that holds up across invocations of
83 chance
um
okay but
in a day in which 83 of the territory is
being rained on at any given moment is
all of it going to be rained on at some
point during that day and isn't that
then there's a 100 chance of rain there
tomorrow right right so there is a
problem uh either it is defined as
something that most people would not be
able to derive
right it was definitely going to rain
here tomorrow but it will only be
raining over 83 of the territory at any
given moment really that's what it means
i thought
it meant something very different so
yeah um
yeah lots of this stuff is not well
defined yeah
okay um
i've noticed the songwriting process
seems disturbingly
evolutionary which also made me think of
how music inspires music is music life
no but
um but you're absolutely right about how
thoroughly evolutionary it is and it's
really in some ways
yeah first of all i should point out the
puzzle was spotted by darwin the
evolutionary explanation for music it
absolutely demands one
um the explanation was completely punted
by stephen pinker who dismissed music uh
or he dismis
dismissed music as the equivalent of
cheesecake
um saying that was just a bunch of good
things that we like in such abundance
that we can't resist it but it doesn't
have any evolutionary meaning
um which uh is nonsense but
anyway i mean he's right about what
cheesecake is
cheesecake is well the difference is
cheesecake is novel right um and music
sure ain't and not ubiquitous right
there are cultures without cheesecake i
feel terrible for them but um but yeah
there are cultures without cheesecake
and there are no cultures without music
and really music would be utterly
ubiquitous every human would have the
experience not only of listening to
music but of producing music themself
um
until very recently so anyway yes it's a
it's a really cool puzzle yeah okay one
more question and then we're gonna drop
the youtube uh stream and uh
and
uh start answering other types of
questions
you may have answered this before but
what are your thoughts on jared
diamond's hypothesis about the
relationship between geography culture
and innovation
i am trying to derive whether that
you're talking is this the gunners germs
i think it's going to be steel although
i'm not
the addition of innovation there um
strikes me as maybe it's also some of
what's in one of his later books i'm
looking at collapses right there on the
bookshelf i don't think so i think we
can get all that from gun storms and
steel um i would say
tremendously positive yeah undoubtedly
there's
uh the devil in the details in some
places but it is amazing how much a few
parameters like
the location of domesticable creatures
which most of us think
lots of creatures are domesticable and
the ones that haven't been domesticated
haven't been domesticated because
nobody's tried but in fact there's a
pretty good list of the characteristics
you need and those animals that were
domestical were highly concentrated in
asia
and asia being uh laid out east west
allowed them to be moved without moving
out of their climatic zone
uh so you can move across longitudes
without inherently changing climate and
ecology but you can't move across
latitudes without doing so right so
basically you had uh both animal and
plant farming uh accruing in certain
cultures that were blessed with
advantages like domestical creatures and
crops that had been moved from wherever
they were domesticated to wherever the
population
was without being disrupted and that
created
enough surplus that you could have
things like specialists and artisans
rather than having everybody
participating and so anyway i'm i would
say i'm
quite compelled that this is at least a
major fraction of the study of why
populations differ in their tendency to
have invented things is
uh it basically comes down to
uh non-random distribution of useful
stuff that gave some populations
advantages over others so that they were
hundreds or thousands of years apart in
technology when they met and fought yep
all right we are going to drop the
youtube stream now